und wir schauen nach florenz auf einen
städtetrip herrliches wetter in
spaziergang durch die stadt angela
merkel dort jetzt gerade ferien angela
merkel auf italienreise man könnte sagen
statt in butter in der ukraine dorthin
hatte sie ukraines präsident selensky
eingeladen um sich in butter ein bild so
sagt er von ihrer russlandpolitik zu
machen
frau merkel macht urlaub in florenz
wolkenloser himmel 18 grad angela merkel
schlendert durch die hauptstadt der
toskana mal mit mal ohne maske und
genießt la dolce vita
gleichzeitig rund 2000 kilometer
entfernt leichen und endlose trauer die
toten von butscher von russischen
truppen hingerichtet bilder die kaum
auszuhalten sind
laut ukraine präsident selensky trägt
urlauberin merkel daran eine mitschuld
ich lade frau merkel und herrn sarkozy
ein mutter zu besuchen und zu sehen wozu
die politik der zugeständnisse an
russland in 14 jahre geführt hat um mit
eigenen augen die gequälten ukrainischen
männer und frauen zu sehen
doch selensky es deutliche worte für alt
kanzlerin merkel kein grund zu reagieren
mit der ehemaligen bildungsministerin
annette schavan bummelt sie stattdessen
durch italien
während hier in botschaft verzweifelte
ukraine ihre geliebten
familienangehörigen in plastiksäcken und
massengräbern verschaffen müssen viele
deutsche meinen merkel sollte sich für
ein ende des horrors einsetzen
es haben ja tatsächlich auch viele
gesagt wenn jemand etwas bewirken kann
dann wahrscheinlich die märkte naja ist
vielleicht kann uns helfen
wenn sie es wollte das ist ihr gutes
recht nein zu sagen und es wollte wer
ist natürlich eine schöne weitere
möglichkeit ist zu versuchen freuen
würde ich mich ich sag mal merkel stand
immer für frieden für wiedervereinigung
in die richtung könnte sie immer ein
zeichen setzen eckig frau merkel stand
immer für eine gewisse art der politik
und ich glaube nicht also jetzt ist die
zeit des kuschelkurs leider vorbei
meiner meinung nach fakt ist angela
merkel sie ist nicht mehr im amt und das
hatte sie nachts lässiges einladungen
vorwürfen bezüglich ihrer früheren
russlands politik auch deutlich gemacht
bundeskanzlerin dr angela merkel stets
ihren entscheidungen im zusammenhang mit
dem nato-gipfel 2008 in bukarest ließ
merkel mit ein damals verhinderten
merkel und sarkozy aus rücksicht auf
russland die aufnahme der ukraine in die
nato aber kann sie sich so leicht aus
der affäre ziehen die frau die
jahrzehntelang verantwortung getragen
hat von medien als die mächtigste frau
der welt und führerin des westens
gefeiert wurde
nein sagt präsident selensky
ich lade frau merkel und herrn sarkozy
ein guter zu besuchen und zu sehen wozu
die politik der zugeständnisse an
russland in 14 jahre geführt hat nach
butscher und kiew kann angela merkel
momentan nicht fliegen aber von rom gibt
es am donnerstag einen flug nach moskau
ja nicht nur präsident selensky fordert
merkel zu einer reise nach butscher auf
auch sehr viel moser war chefredakteurin
der ukrainischen zeitung ukrainska
pravda tut das und schreibt einen
brandbrief an unsere ehemalige kanzlerin
und darin heißt es
all diese werte die sie über so viele
jahre hinweg versucht haben zu
verteidigen könnten heute zerstört
werden um die eu zu retten müssen sie in
die öffentliche politik zurückkehren
ja sie fordert also dass angela merkel
zurück kehrt in die politik